the optimism and generosity of your
remarks was very compelling and you
talked very briefly at the end about the
notion that there may be a few obstacles
are a few impediments in a few places
and yet you know there are vast swathes
of this earth that have yet to become
stable democratic countries so I
wondered whether you'd be willing to to
extrapolate you know expand a little bit
on the kinds of things that from your
experience represented surmountable
obstacles in other words things that
people would say well this is really an
impediment Georgia will never become
democratic and yet you know questions of
corruption questions of development so
forth and so on how how exportable is
the Georgian experience I think first of
all I mean all these things are
universal I mean accountable government
transparency control by the people I
mean daily control checks and balances
these are the things that you cannot
invent the bicycle I mean the way that's
how it is you have independent media you
have civil society you have checks and
balances within government you have
transparency and accountability and you
have the result now of course there is
always I mean there are also different
models that could be I mean for instance
if you have too many special interests
having poor purely parliamentary
government where parliamentary groups
groups have to come together and have to
make a coalition government can be
detrimental to initial stage I mean us
model is much more adjustable situations
with strong executive but strong
Parliament strong strong legislature
because what it brings it brings the
system of checks and balances where
exactly we did its functions is less
limited by the legislature can have
strong oversight I think for societies
in transition this model is
or is better from any point of view
because special interest will not
prevail and basically swallowing all the
resources of the society because direct
rule of the people can often be kind of
overshadowed with this special interest
that they do exist and we know it from
ourselves you know how we pulled
ourselves from other mud with our own
shoe strings was initially I came in the
we didn't have cash to pay any salaries
I mean I came into my office and two
weeks after being prep resident a game
babli brought me my paycheck in an
envelope and guess how much president of
Georgia was making before me it was 20
US dollars per two weeks so forty
dollars per month and when they brought
me I thought they were I don't know
didn't know what it was and when they
told me it was my salary I thought they
were making fun of me because my
predecessor was very rich is he still
one of the richest men in our own
country his ministers who used to get
even less we're no longer i'm in their
houses are the biggest one still in the
capital and did they enjoyed nice
lifestyles I mean with all this meager
salaries so but there was nothing of
course nothing was left to the
government and to the people so for 15
years nobody thought about paving roads
nobody fault about constructing schools
nobody thought about I mean propping up
at least some kind of military nobody
thought about I mean like the way how
police function in our case was that the
police were told we are not going to pay
you any salaries you have to earn your
own living with bribes we are not going
to put gasoline into your cars but you
need to have some kind of cars which we
are not going to provide you need to
wear some kind of uniform which we are
not going to provide but you should buy
it from your corrupt income and not only
we are not going to pay you anything but
you have to bring us back monthly
payments for what you get from your poor
population
of course in such a system everybody was
corrupt but the point is that there are
many countries in the world when there
is such a system in different forms and
when basically the government is
licensed to live at the expense of their
peoples now when we came in we said we
needed initial cash to pay sellers so we
ask money from you and deep united
nations development program to pay
initial money for salaries to a few
dozen of anti-corruption investigators
and few hundred tax collectors it
enabled us to have basically double our
tax collection within very short period
and then we started to pay to the others
now no official and Georgia gets lower
than minimum survival rate and some of
the sellers a rather high I mean
considering our GDP per capita I think
one of the higher highest in some cases
in Eastern Europe I mean in terms of
salaries because this is essential the
first stage was to fix the government
bureaucracy the second stage is to do
wider projects now because we have
higher tax collection then people should
see the difference they were tolerant
for the first year they were I mean
somebody who has been getting twenty
doors as a pension was tolerant to see
that some minister is getting three to
four to five thousand dollars a month
but they are Toland we explained to them
but its necessary to it will improve
their livelihoods later later we have to
show the results and we are now building
roads the whole country is under
construction we are building new power
stations built to curb power shortages
and this is something very visible or
the people can touch it i mean it's
there we're building schools we are
building hospitals and this is something
else at the same time by liberalizing
system and moving the government away
from the way of business because i don't
believe in strong government
interference i don't believe in any
government interference in business
frankly i mean there was this temptation
among some of my friends as well with
noble intention to say you know now we
are going to go and get them we are
going to get all these greedy oligarchs
we are going to rape privatize we're
going
to you know change things you know bae
cordoning business community well this
is the worst thing you can do because
it's none of government's business the
government should what freedom means
that you should leave them alone and you
should give them guarantees that they
will be left alone except that you
should give guarantees that if they have
debates with each other if they have
disputes to be settled judiciary will be
efficient enough to help them to provide
remedy so that these are the stages of
the way we are working and again it's
extremely important to have a
certification government with strong
control from the legislature end and
from the media but on the other hand
it's very important to understand that
there's in some cases where government
should not should stay behind should not
intervene in order to for country to be
successful and that's another lesson we
learnt this is a very tough lesson by
the way if you are coming from Soviet
past you always have this temptation to
go into the micromanagement of the thing
of private citizens activities and every
the even the most noble intentions
usually bring us to very bad results I
think that's if you look at our
experience we had nine percent growth
last year or not eight points seven I
think this year we are expecting ten
percent growth but the main thing that
happened that the income but
redistributed and people there is the
middle class emerged and that's my main
result i would say because I mean it's
not so much the increase of gdp per
capita as the increase of people who can
already be well off I mean forty-five
percent of our population described in
the polls themselves identify their
condition as fair economically ten
percent said that they are doing very
well now two years ago it was only five
percent and this is self in the
identification I am NOT saying that they
are saying this which means that people
have got some economic optimism and
middle class is emerging and I think
middle-class Indian longer run is the
main stability force for democracy and
for sustainable democratic free
development for every society where it
emerges and I think this is another
thing that's coming in the world in
general middle class is getting larger
and larger I mean you can see it you can
see by consumers panic you can see by
also and the higher classes be shrinking
I mean they really the wealthiest ones
their number is not growing anymore and
it's even shrinking and this is a very
important process process that's what
makes the whole thing irreversible I
must say this is a fascinating lesson in
how one constructs a democracy and not
internally consistent with some of the
platitudes in an event that the
democracy promoters often argue because
you are insistence on actually building
government capacity and then saying that
there is a distinction between the
government and the private sector is a
fairly sophisticated way of approaching
this and clearly reasonably successful
would you say in a way you're you're
playing two roles right now on the one
hand it's called the rose revolution you
are in a revolutionary on the other hand
you want to sort of institutionalize
this and become merely a democratic
leader is that a difficult tension yes
yes it is because what we am saying is
that on the one hand we revolution
itself was just initial stage I mean
what followed was cultural revolution
and cultural revolution is to continue
changing perceptions and for that we
need to create constantly be creating
framework I mean we're a small country
of Leslie to be less than 5 million
people so it's but still a country that
where we basically have this role of
framers role of framers and when when
you're framing something you also want
to be part of that system and of course
this is a always a tough challenge
because
on the other hand it's just a regular
democratic process you get elections you
get criticism you respond to criticism
and there you can no not play really i
mean the founding father role no you are
just down on the ground and it's like
it's not being part of great gallery of
historic heroes i mean it is not the for
the time being i mean this is something
that is business as usual right but on
the other hand yet i think the main
thing we do to stay behind us is
cultural revolution and this will make
the whole process here versatile and i
think this is happening in georgia this
is happening in ukraine but also in the
former Soviet Union even if there was no
regime to change in other places
attitudes and perceptions also ruling
elites are dramatically changing I mean
they the first reaction was that of fear
and panic I mean what's going on it's
going to come also to our countries we
are going to have mass but I think now
people started to understand that first
full revolutions and upheavals cannot be
provoked by opposition only I mean it's
a both way straight if the government is
stupid enough to all the time make
mistakes and basically respond to even
provocations from the opposition then
it's doomed but if Kermit the smart
enough to preempt them to adjust and to
make changes then I mean why should
somebody be changing reduced by taking
hundreds of thousand people to the
streets and standing there for
increasing grain for many weeks or
months no it's not I mean so what's
really happening we are seeing that
reform process I'm sure will become
Universal in many places and I've been
meeting with four other CIS leaders and
they've been very realistic about it you
look what happened in Egypt I mean
people are critical critical about some
aspects of Egyptian political system but
for the first time the reality is that
for the first time there was an open
debate there
I mean there were candidates they were
could speak on television they could get
a big there we used known and that was
normal I mean nobody was I mean not even
nobody was so much surprised by did you
like normal three four or five years ago
it was unimaginable what happened in
lemon I mean the way they conduct a
public campaign it was unimaginable few
years ago so what I'm seeing is that
people everywhere started to understand
that you know it's not so simple anymore
life will never be the same anymore and
those that don't understand that they're
on their way out well I certainly hope
so I have one more set of questions so
those of you who are beginning to think
of your questions should prepare
yourselves and that's really to talk a
little bit you've you've taught you
talked in your introductory remarks
about the role that the democracy
promotion of the bush administration has
played and even now you've talked about
the notion that Georgia represents
something of a model or an example to
other countries what is the role that
Outsiders can play in democratic in
promoting democracy I think the main
outsider that helped us a lot I already
mentioned it was CNN and television in
general and media exposure and and their
moral support that it generates among
other people I don't think you can
artificially provoke anything you cannot
pay for people to be in the street it's
not possible it's even if you can
sometimes I mean I guess but you know
those people to whom you pay whatever
amount you paid they won't stay there
for a long time that's I mean if people
don't they don't feel like being very
desperate even if they are even if you
paid them like hundred dollars an hour
they will stay there for a couple of
hours in the rain and all said they'd
had enough in to go home I mean be happy
with those money that they got
and so the whole idea is that you know
they were paying their money they were
changed in special camps I think even
people who kind of circulated those
ideas no longer believe in them paint
David themselves understood that it's
much more much more profound process and
the process is based in natural human
longing for freedom and for alternatives
and for debates and for their own
participation and empowerment no matter
how prosperous societies are no matter
what's the GDP per capita no matter
what's the level of retirement benefits
pensions you know unemployment benefits
if people don't feel that they are asked
they're going to revolt and protest
that's the rule and even in the poorest
societies if people feel that their they
can express themselves they can their
views can be heard that there we do
matter revolutions are not going to
happen even violent uprisings or mass
protests are not going to be that often
because people feel that there'd be you
know I was recently I met some young
person from from a very well of country
i mean in asia and that's doing very
well and in like whenever heard that he
was from there i told him all good for
you i mean the country is doing very
well I mean you know it's like I've seen
on television nice cool skyscrapers if
all things he said who cares we want
democracy I mean we want more democracy
I mean it's not about all this means and
this is this is true I mean if you are
in person it's not all about they I mean
the benefits you get you want to be part
of it you want to have ownership in it
not to be just some kind of personal and
hired by somebody else and i think
that's that's the main driving force
behind the change can-can other
governments support democracy are there
things that government should or should
not do too
say yes we want to help the democratic
forces well of course there is always
important to express position I think
what counts is moral support and
political position and I don't believe I
mean I worried that some people were
saying the fact that secretary said
something in support of democracy in
Middle East some Democrats in the middle
is where damage as a result I don't
think it's true I don't believe it's
true i mean it's yes those who wear I
mean tho those people who thought that
they were damaged I mean they oh they
are the enemies of freedom anyway I mean
they would look for any reasons to think
that way but otherwise I mean any kind
of disposition is also always very
helpful okay wonderful there are
microphones in both the aisles so those
of you who would like to ask questions
should prepare yourself sir you were
there first mr. president thanks so much
for your presentation my name is Talon
sultanov I'm a student here at school of
international affairs from Kyrgyzstan
yeah i know kyrgyzstan was the country
that following the example of georgia
had also such a revolution but the
problem i think now with our government
is that if you get to the old corrupt
government you have new corrupt
officials that just well apparently
coming to the power house georgia
fighting this problem of corruption and
how sustainable are your reforms for
example if you get rid of all the
officials in the interior minister the
police you have to find jobs for these
people who are fired and how do you make
sure that the new people are not taking
bribes and are honest very simple i mean
we first of all the main recipe here is
not to be afraid because first of all
those we prepared the whole traffic
police now most of them had savings
because they were corrupt and you know
like the my ideal is a policeman opening
a grocery store in the street and taking
off his uniform
now the problem is that we had police
office having a grocery store or
controlling grocery store and being a
policeman now we separated those two and
that's the way to it i mean i don't
think to become a police officer you
need ten years of extensive training at
columbia at sea port somewhere no two
months of police academy would do in
proper system and i think there are many
checks and balances first of all their
salaries were increased 12 times at
least in some cases 40 times 50 times in
terms of high-level officials second the
whole climate in society changed every
night we have show like cops on George
and television police love it because
they're heroes they are covered on
television people know about them and
it's really becoming shameful to be
corrupted because you are out of system
I mean it's no longer fashionable this
is important I mean no matter how much
you pay unless you create this climate
it's not going to work so this is this
is the the issue and in terms of
corruption it's not only about like
hearsay like item saying we don't know
we have no corruption somebody says
maybe they're corrupt there are lots of
people who are saying in Georgia I'm
from the opposition know this government
in 10 times more corrupt than previous
however George's overall aggregate
budget for the last two years Cru eight
times eight times this is the figure of
index of reduction of corruption local
budgets and central budget together no
matter who says what is the reality
eight times more money is going to the
government instead of going into the
pockets and of course we are a free
country that people might say there are
people who say that I've been sarka
shuli is worse than anybody else deposit
and I mean everything is corrupting but
the results are here we for the 15 years
of rule of my predecessor seven
kilometres of roads were built in
Georgia seven kilometers this year we
are this year only we are building 350
next year we'll build 600 to 800 this is
the difference I mean this is the first
year with Georgia fioretti lately
have energy shortages we had huge
shortages this was country you know in
darkness for many many years and this is
the result and many many others have
many many other things I mean so it's
just the reality is that if you are ever
and I don't believe that you know like
if we don't get experience of issues
from previous government the country is
going to collapse I think there are love
knowledgeable people in societies you
just need to find them I'm you should
you go back and you stay should take you
at the point that some minister may be
Prime Minister I don't know what I mean
we've been doing some experiments like
this sometimes they were good sometimes
not a time one of these experiments so I
think the Krishna has some good
prospects I just spoke to her president
by the way and I think he had a sense
what should be done is it white yeah my
name is Ricardo bre I'm a doctoral
student in economics and education here
and I'm Albanian so I know a little or a
little thing or two about the evilness
of the communist regime I was in Georgia
the summer of 2004 and i really want to
congratulate you because i already
witnessed Georgian people being a lot
more enthusiastic about their future and
the country had already started to
reconstruct my question is about China
one of the last strongholds of communism
in the world right now and oh there has
been a detour 'i'll piece by a newspaper
it's a it's called ebook times and it's
it's chinese edition actually published
a piece called nine commentaries on a
communist party inspired by this piece
in brief what this is is a uncensored
account of the violence and deception
the Communist Chinese Communist Party
has used to keep itself in power and
inspired by this article to date there
are four point two million Chinese
people inside and outside China
renouncing their membership to the
Communist Party or other comedy
organizations and a lot of China
observers think that this is the
beginning of the end of the communism in
China and the company chinese communist
party will be sold soon and it seemed
like you were optimistic about that in
general so I have two questions one is
about what is your prediction about
communism in the world today particular
reference to China a country which is
also supporting oppressive regimes in
countries i believe it was cookie-san
there were reports that they were trying
to help the government their escape the
long line the public okay I'll cut it
short and raise dating actually the
question of Dean Anderson about what can
the government of democratic countries
do to support these Democratic movements
in these countries it seems like we have
double standards so we have embargo for
Cuba but we have foreign investment for
China and it seems as suddenly for
investment seems like a way to help the
democracy in a country like China but
not in other countries and looking at
the history of eastern communist
countries it was that economic isolation
that really brought down these communist
governments so what is your comment on
that well thank you i mean first of all
i don't believe that companies has any
future i mean i don't believe in it in
general i believe that i mean i could I
mean I I grew up in a family where
communists were always hated but because
of that most of that family has been
destroyed in Stalin's purges and my
great-grandfather who died when I was 17
years old and I grew basically his home
whole house will spend 12 years in
Siberia his brother was 20 20 years
they're all brothers of my grandmother
was shot and her father was killed so I
mean we know it firsthand I mean and you
know that the last year there was the
pole I don't know whether it's I mean
the pole is Right whether you share the
same experience but George's were second
most optimistic people in Europe but the
Albanians where
first most optimistic people here oh no
I mean if you are coming out of the
country of anwar haji it's no wonder
that you might be optimizing everything
kind of it but nothing can be I mean we
were worse or everything looks better
than under recoja that's obvious and and
but the reality is that i don't think
communist has any future because it's it
skills competition it kills for freedom
of thought side it's what it really
brings is that midi up many mediocre
people succeed it kills talent because
the way it is you know when i was first
year student at university they put me
on the blacklist of KGB and i was
finished I would never have got job ha
maybe I wouldn't have been arrested but
I would be unemployed I would be always
under watchful eye of communist party or
KGB and you know if you will try to
belittle if they noticed that you were
kind of out of mainstream a minute they
were finished and normally no educate
and talented people that's how they
normally are right the Communist
cultivates this mediocre personalities
that's the reality and that's something
that was proved many times and examples
of many countries now how to treat
concrete countries it's very hard to say
I don't believe in say isolating China I
don't believe it how can you isolate
China I mean this is China can isolate
anybody else if it wants to this is this
is a huge economy very rapidly growing
one very dynamic I mean am i and i would
say that i wouldn't agree on assessment
of chinese foreign policy my
understanding is china has been behaving
in foreign policy very moderate rain
many respects unlike some other
countries I don't don't didn't know
everybody think about Q gusta now
talking about views about general
political systems I already told you i
mean i don't believe that i believe
thats a liberal democracy has no
alternative for anybody new
world and as I told you you'll be
witness that every country will live
within such system in the foreseeable
future sir Sir Chris Baldwin's graduate
school journalism sir the I Rex the
international research and exchange
board an NGO instrumental in cultivating
democracy in the former Soviet Union by
providing educational opportunities for
outstanding scholars from these
countries among other things including
yourself here at Columbia with the
muskie fellowship has been kicked out of
booze Becca Stan systematically the
korean mob regime is eliminating the
very institutions that were key in
Georgia and Ukraine and Kyrgyzstan what
options are left to the use of becca
people and how important are these civil
society and democracy building
institutions well I mean the problem
with such a first of all I'd really
agree on about the important role to be
played by actors like I Rex already
other especially educational
institutions because without them I
would have stood no chance to come here
no chance I mean we I came here and I
keep kept complaining about as in the
beginning of my speech about in a
toughness of New York environment but on
the other hand I found herself in
absolutely exclusive environment i mean
my professor the name of my professors
included not only for is kofi annan but
also who is present secretary-general of
the UN but also oscar chapter who wrote
the charter of the UN who just died two
years ago unfortunately but I mean
people who were made history who were
historic themselves and
I remember and look Hank eNOS was
teaching me international law and he was
like he was also himself living memory
of everything that happened here i mean
he he would it was 93 and he would go
and talk about some topics say about 50s
and he would say but the fact that this
convention was not signed then was their
fault and point at me like i was former
Soviet student everything why why should
I take blame for crucial Brezhnev
installed and sorry I mean I was
approached by glue Hank and I said
Professor I mean please leave me alone I
mean I have nothing to do with them but
the the reality is that education is the
key and why what's happening now for
instance in Windows they set up an
University for students from Belarus and
lots of young activists from services
that they are coming there to study and
I think this is the think we should
spread information which would give them
education we should cultivate civil
society we should talk more about this I
mean all international channels are
available everywhere else I mean BBC
world can be seen everywhere abbr CNN is
everywhere you know Voice of America is
everywhere just talk about that you know
there might be that we were desperate
when in Georgia for some days I was a
Georgia was covered better I'll tell you
why because when Georgia things were
happening people were expecting violence
so CNN immediately arrived on the spot p
ABC was on the spot everybody was on the
spot waiting when we will start to kill
each other in case of Ukraine I mean for
weeks nobody would show up except the
Georgians having the who may be cashed
in on renting out their equipment later
because when Western has finally
understood that something is happening
they came in with one suitcase without
any special equipment and George and
equipment was already there well but we
were desperate because things are
happening they're faking elections and
nobody speaks about it
what's going on so if this thing's
really do matter about this specific
situation there should be more
discussion and I'm sure that that will
inevitably produce such a moral thing
value that I mean you sit somewhere you
think the world has forgotten about you
and suddenly somebody comes out Syme
some air expert like you from Colombian
speaks about situation in the X country
I mean every freedom loving person in
that country would immediately cheer up
and say we have hope so that's the
things that should be done I will take
only one last question I'm really sorry
I mean I'm he has things to do as you
can well imagine you have the
opportunity here my name is Andrew
harder i'm a student at the School of
International and public affairs you
already alluded to this earlier in your
remarks but I'm curious if you can
elaborate on how you would like or what
you would like your own legacy to be and
specifically mean to what extent does
your ideal legacy involve a reimagining
of George's international policy perhaps
re orientation towards Europe perhaps
eventual membership in the European
Union many years off oh but a general
just a more independent international
personality for your country and and
then how would you how are you hoping to
go about doing that over the coming
years well we we don't have global
ambitions we are a small country trying
to survive in a very complicated
geopolitical environment however I'm in
Georgia inspired to the Georgian example
inspired lots of people all around the
world and this that's inspiring for us
as well I mean we a president bush came
to George and spoke about Georgia like
its abuse Pekin of Liberty he said for
the whole world and Georgia's you
Georgia he told us created one of the
most important moments of history and
what small nation would not be proud of
such remarks I mean I we were proud we
are still very proud so this is one
thing the other is Georgia Eastern
European country now it's matter of
recognizing it is matter of getting
there
I believe that there is a realistic
chance within my presidential term that
I'm into whoo under Constitution I might
have two terms i'm talking about first
term that ends by the end of 2008 to
speak about Georges integration into
NATO I mean we are speaking about it we
have realistic expectations about it and
I think it's fixed I think things are
going to move much faster than people
would imagine now once we saw problem
with NATO we also regard this as entry
ticket to other European institutions
because it's guarantee for further
economic development for democratic
development for further empowerment of
our people and for more enthusiasm and
hope and I think today against it's
still I mean many things appear to be
very you know yet blink and unresolved
amid of course but few years ago when
they started to speak about accession of
Baltic countries to NATO people thought
that it was a joke former Soviet
countries in NATO it was unconceivable
for ninety percent of the Europeans it
happened not only the NATO but then the
European Union has happened nobody
fought about Romania Bulgaria just few
years ago it's happening it's happening
and no matter what it's going to matter
they are already NATO and it will they
will also join the European Union and so
are we we are in the region from where
of whom most of the people have never
heard before right as I told you when I
was here we were fighting bloody war
with forces that came into Georgia from
Russia basically Russian troops nobody
cared about it because I remember very
well Carey Hart whom you might remember
I mean I certainly remember him very
well because when I was a child
I he was a big superstar in American
politics and he came to speak to this
not to this whole to the other one the
the other building it was he was invited
by school of political science and it
was 93 and of course he was kind of very
critical of Clinton at that time you
know like it was visible that clinic he
was saying that Clinton basically took
his role he said Clinton was junior
aided my campaign this guy has no brains
I mean his wife his guiding him things
like that I mean he was pretty nest and
then at certain moment and this was like
my hero i always thought it was big
charismatic figure at certain moment by
criticizing clinton he went as far as to
say and this was the moment when georgia
is fighting war and I'm nervous that
nobody cares and and contin made some
statement about us a few days before he
was the only one even then that made
statement no European leader cared about
George a bed for me and he said he went
he is so unserious that he even made
this stupid statement and said why in
the world should we care about
territorial integrity of some Republic
of Georgia and this was like heaven the
very second he died for me as a person I
mean I hear he got totally destroyed he
committed political suicide in my eyes
and I was like what I mean where we are
some certain country that nobody should
care about that's what he said and by
the way also by when I met Clinton I
wanted to thank him about them in the
end in the but I was like thank you for
making that statement that Gary heard
didn't like but the reality was such
that 12 years ago saying that one day
President of the United States will go
to this certain country of Georgia and
proclaim that it's example the whole
world is unimaginable so after that
nothing is unimaginable
more I mean it says they definitely will
get to the European Union faster than
people go to Mars and they're going to
go to Mars quite soon okay thank you
very much poor thing